what was your motivation to become a
judge and devote your life to law do not
bother with the words and nor thing in
our family so we served in something I
thought about Anza College University a
lot like a lawyer and the lawyer is a
person we have seven people and they
have to be concerned about a few also
have user head total loss to the head
and a heart everybody has a heart and
everybody has a head if you have a good
head as well as a good heart you will be
sucking the water so it's perfectly
combined so to the federal judge in this
country that is wise in England is
something you do in mid-career you see
in your forties or fifties and federal
judges appointed by the President of the
United States and confirmed by the
Senate of the United States there are
trial judges appeals urging the Supreme
Court I was appointed the Court of
Appeals 1980 by President Carter and was
then I served in Boston which is in
charge of that region which is several
states there in Puerto Rico for 14 years
and then 22 Supreme Court by President
Clinton the job of the Supreme Court in
the United States is to interpret and
apply federal law that was passed by
Congress and the Constitution the United
States typically with lower court to
disagree of meaning of the text or the
application of a constitutional
provision we do have to find a word of
what they mean Congress can change the
meaning at the tax because they can
write a new tax it is the statute it is
the Constitution they can and therefore
this court in the typical year has run
70 or so cases probably maybe half or a
third of those are constitutional and
some of our cases might see increase
incredibly trivial what is the meaning
of a comma in the Internal Revenue Code
or they could involve a major
constitutional question such as the what
is the prisoners in Guantanamo I have
the right to go to court to complain to
their
lawfully or as in 1954 whether it was
constitutional Constitution says that
every person is entitled to equal
protection of the law so the south of
the United States as well now before
1954 raises are segregated and those who
were black at much worse conditions than
those who worldwide it was a little bit
like South Africa Department and the
court in 1954 held that that was
contrary to the Constitution in minute
of a long time to make that effective so
to this day not completely exactly but
the legal apparatus and surrounded that
incredible really careful system of
segregation who gradually dismiss them
over time other books